hey guys it's justine and today i'm
going to show you this all new home
fitness product
this is the tempo studio
[Music]
[Applause]
now i partnered with tempo to make this
video for you guys but before i agreed i
had to make sure i tested this thing out
thoroughly to make sure i actually
really liked it
and so for the past several weeks i've
been using this i just started a
four-week program and today is gonna be
the day that i'm doing my last workout
in this four week program for the past
few months i've been spending so much
time at home unable to go to my gym like
i normally could but this thing has so
far
surpassed all of my expectations for
what i can actually do while i'm at home
with virtual trainers it's incredible
and i can't wait to show it to you
[Music]
this is the tempo studio it's an
all-in-one home gym that takes
performance tracking to a whole new
level and
it's the only system that gives you
instant feedback to improve your form it
uses 3d motion sensors and ai to analyze
your movements and count your reps
weight lifted calories burned and more
as you progress
it will increase your weight
recommendations and customize the
programming to help fit your fitness
goals
whatever they are the weights are
olympic-grade steel barbells and
dumbbells that adjust from 7.5
to 115 pounds and there's a nice neat
place to store them when they aren't in
use
you'll use these plus body weight in
strength cardio and hit classes led by
certified trainers
this whole cabinet just feels premium
like everything about it feels
so nice and this is a 42 inch
touchscreen so that's how you're able to
navigate different classes
and what's really awesome about this
i've taken 18 classes so far and if i
scroll down here
it's giving you all of the stats of
everything that you've done throughout
the course of your classes
i'm not too thrilled with my personal
records but i've actually never really
done much weightlifting before so this
has completely changed the way that i've
started to work out so show you guys the
interface
i mean it feels just like a big phone
it's so crazy so since i first got this
i just decided to try the four week
challenge so that it would guide me
through a course just to be able to get
a sense of
all the classes that they had to offer i
also like that you can choose what part
of the body you want to work out so
here's like a legs and glutes you have
core
upper body so it'll show you all of the
things that you're going to be doing
before you actually do them and this is
super helpful
because if you do have an injury or
something you'll be able to say okay i'm
not able to do planks today
so let me choose a different workout i
also really love the social aspect of
this because i'm able to compete with my
friends and challenges just to add that
extra motivation so as soon as my sister
gets one of these
it's on so this is the class that we're
going to be doing this is the 30 minute
full body strength and conditioning it
shows you everything that we're going to
be doing
in this course and this is a beginner
which is probably pretty good for me
our equipment the music duration let's
freaking do it
like this bar is already heavy enough so
let's put on our recommended amount of
weights and what's really cool with ai
tracking is it's able to recommend
heavier or lighter weights
as you progress or if you think it's too
heavy you're able to change the weights
manually
just to let them know hey i'm not ready
so with this sensor it's able to pick up
your body movement and give you
real-time adjustments so one of the
things that this has helped me with so
much
is i never realized how bad i was at
doing squats
until this started giving me the
real-time correction it let me know
every time my knees
went over my toes and i was able to make
that adjustment and it gave me that
feedback and then it was like
good job and directly under the sensor
is where all of your weights are and i
honestly just cannot get over how
great this looks this also comes in a
black finish but this is the white
version
and all of your weights are stored here
so if you're 10 pounds you're five pound
two and a half
and one point two five and these are the
barbell clips so these are what clips on
to the barbells
which are conveniently stored behind
this entire machine
so let me take you guys back there to
see where all of those are stored
this is so great because you can just
pop these right off very quickly
come back over here pop on your weights
and then when you're done
they're stored very nicely right behind
and you never have to see them
if you got one of these and you're
looking for the power button it's right
[Music]
here
right weights are on these might be a
little heavy for me
but we're gonna hit continue and i can
adjust as we get started
[Music]
so up here is where you'll be able to
adjust your weights so this is the
recommended weight that we're using
right now but you can click adjust
weights so if i want it to be heavier do
do add it also gives you the color
coordination so it's easy to switch
[Music]
i love they have a nice mixture between
weights cardio and body weight
so it is a nice mixture in all of these
classes
so calf raises
oh time to switch we're going on to the
barbell so here's the recommended
weights
i think this might be a little heavy for
me so i'm going to adjust it here
manually because i already
know that i think we should turn this
down and what's great is this will learn
the weights so as i adjust this to what
works for me
the system gets smarter and it'll know
next time did i
do a good job with this weight do i need
to add some do i need to take some off
so it gets smarter
as you get more fit
[Music]
so that was the feedback that i was
talking about so it let me know that my
knees were over my toes
and i'm able to correct that as i
continue on to do that exercise
i'm out of breath okay dead lift time
[Music]
looks like we're moving on to the floor
to do some chest presses so we have
another weight change on the dumbbells
so let's put those on
and get to it
[Music]
foreign
uh
and that was it for that class at the
end it gives you the option to rate the
class you can leave some comments
this is your strength profile so based
on your performance will adjust your
starting weights for similar exercises
in the future
this is really interesting because it
does use ai to determine what you'll be
able to lift next time
if you want to go up in weights so
having used this for the past several
weeks
it's been amazing because i'm the type
of person before who would only go to
group fitness classes that's how i would
do almost all of my own workouts i'm not
very good at figuring out what things i
should be doing and what i shouldn't be
doing so this is like having one of
those personal fitness trainers in your
house
i really love the weights because the
barbell itself is a stainless steel
olympic grade barbell and dumbbell and
these weights are rubberized so these
are less likely to damage your floors if
you have hardwood floors this also comes
with a foam roller so this is great for
after or before workouts
i love this because it's also being
updated with new classes and new
features
and this just happens real time over the
air you can just update it through wi-fi
and they do have
a future integration with the apple
watch which i cannot wait for that
update to roll out
all in all i absolutely love this and i
really have tested this out for the past
month just to make sure that this was
something that actually did work the
classes were solid but the equipment was
well made
everything about it is really amazing
and what is really so great
is the fact that it does look like a
small cabinet that could be put anywhere
in your house
and still look pretty cool i mean i
really can't say enough good things
about it so i'm very excited and
maybe in a few months i'm going to be so
ripped and shredded it's getting there
well thank you guys so much for watching
this was really a fun video and i really
did test this out for the past several
weeks just to make sure that this was
something that i could completely stand
by
and say this is awesome it works and i
love it so if you guys are interested in
checking this out and getting more
information i'll put a link in the
description
anyway thank you again for watching and
i will see you guys in the next video
bye
you